so let's now get to donald trump's
minnesota rally on friday night
this one was bizarre and surreal
one such surreal moment was donald trump
still unaware
that ruth bader ginsburg had died starts
talking about the supreme court
and you can actually hear people in the
background yelling ginsburg
is dead people in the crowd who have
heard the news on their phone for
example
you're actually going to hear as donald
trump is just sitting up there like a
fool
ranting about the supreme court you will
because it's so quiet because the crowd
doesn't know what to make of these
bizarre rants by donald trump
you can actually pick out you'll hear
two female voices about 10 seconds in
and then a male voice about 30 seconds
in yelling ginsburg is dead
totally surreal people on the stage
behind trump starting to look around
as news starts to spread and that's why
the supreme court is so important the
next president
will get one two three or four supreme
court justices i had to
many presidents have had none they've
had none because they're there for a
long time
they tend to be appointed young they're
there for a long time
but the next one will have anywhere from
one to four think of that
that will totally change when you talk
about life when you talk about
second amendment when you talk about
things that are so important to you
you're going to be stuck for 40 years 35
years a long time
so this is going to be the most
important
election in my opinion just surreal is
the only word i can think of to describe
this environment trump earlier in the
rally
going on an unusual screed about
how robert e lee would have won the
civil war
had it not been for gettysburg trump
outrageously praising the top general
in the fight to maintain slavery in the
united states
during the civil war and uh he was
getting beaten a lot by robert e lee
they want to rip the statue down all
over the place but robert e lee
robert e lee was a whether you like him
or not whether you like
statues or not you know they don't rip
statues down anymore assigned to law
ten years in jail better
but robert e lee won many many battles
in a row
and it was supposed to be over in one
day you know it's supposed to end
immediately because the north was too
powerful
for the south but it just shows when you
have
leaders when you have a great general
and robert e lee he would have won
except for gettysburg and that was
because his
general was killed who's going to lead
gettysburg
never fight uphill me boys never fight
uphill he heard they were going uphill
stop them stop them but we had no cell
phones in that day right
congressmen no cell phones so they sent
the horses to stop them stop them but it
was too late they fought uphill and they
got
slaughtered that's what happened but
robert e lee these were
incredible things and then you might
have noticed they're on top of just a
ridiculous outrageous
message donald trump slurring his way
through this one as well
gettysburg as you heard there uh trump
early in the rally did some pretty
direct racist red meat here he is
talking about whether people are
enjoying having
refugees around particularly odd because
at least some of these refugees came in
during donald trump's presidency this is
part of donald trump running on changing
the country
even though he's been president for the
last four years
one of the most vital issues in this
election
is the subject of refugees you know it
you know it perhaps better than almost
anybody lots of luck you're having a
good time with your refugees that's good
we want to have omar he said omar that's
a beauty how the hell did she win the
election
how did she win
these are rallies unlike anything we've
seen
in american history outside obscure
white nationalist kkk type candidates
and
uh authoritarian dictators in the 20th
century
mostly in other countries that's what
these rallies remind me of
trump seems completely unaware that he's
the incumbent
rather than an outsider he keeps talking
as if
winning in november would be a change in
leadership
he's been president for four years
you're going to win so much
and you're going to send jason to the
u.s senate
and you're going to keep winning and
winning and winning
you're going to win on trade you're
going to win on the military you're
going to win
on everything you touch minnesota is
going to keep on winning
and you're going to get tired of winning
because minnesota doesn't want to win
all the time your football team is going
to win in the big ten they say right
now we're going to keep on winning in
minnesota and you're going to get so
tired you're going to say
jason jason please please jason
go to the president see him in the oval
office so
if if that topic is interesting to you
trump running as if someone else has
been president
check out my youtube clip from a couple
of weeks ago called trump running as if
someone else has been president
and then again donald trump raising this
idea of so-called patriotic education
it's still not totally clear what it
means but it's certainly not good
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
big deal we will teach our children to
love our country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
this continues to play on the notion
that education is some kind of left-wing
indoctrination
instead of just recognizing the reality
that the more people know how to think
the more people uh have critical
thinking and epistemology skills
the less likely they are to fall for the
bamboozling of donald trump and the
republican party
trump at one point urged the my pillow
guy mike lindell to run
run for governor of minnesota just tell
them i'm very unhappy
right this is what these guys are good
businessmen by the way these guys right
here mike
they might be better than you i don't
even know he may be the next governor
you know mike lindell may be
you should run you should run
that's another one of those moments
where uh trump
is saying uh let me put it this way
let me put it a different way when trump
says something this crazy
twenty percent of what's sick is that
trump is saying it
eighty percent of what's sick is that
the crowd claps and that the crowd will
go
forever anything trump says trump then
told a totally incoherent story
the likes of which we would normally
hear from like some drunk guy at a bar
so i said to the general i said general
uh 5.7 billion billion not me
billion that sounds very hard to me
general
i bought a lot of planes in my life and
a lot of helicopters i know a lot about
it
how could it be five sir that's the best
price they could get
we only have one day to do it
i said cancel a general cancel the order
it was signed actually
yes sir i said you have the right to
cancel yes sir i do
we negotiated a great deal i said oh
good trump has this uncanny ability
to get these crowds to be completely
silent during his strange stories
in this clip trump still seems confused
about whether stealth planes
are literally invisible to the naked eye
rather
than just being invisible to radar
they're bigger
they're more powerful they're smarter
and i like tom cruise by the way because
i mean you can't get much better than
top gun right great movie right you
can't get better i like tom cruise but
these guys are better looking than
they got the crew cut they got the crap
under their eyes they got the whole deal
they're smart as hell so i said so
captain let me ask you how good is the
f-35 real good sir best player we've
ever had oh great
i said uh how do you compare that with
uh what russia has
well ours is better for a specific
reason sir you can't see it
what does that mean well when we fight
they cannot see us sir we are so stealth
now that doesn't mean in three years
that it won't be obsolete because that's
what happens that's the problem with
that business
of course military equipment getting
obsolete
it's it's actually a feature of the
military industrial complex
and then trump slurred his way through
telling the crowd
that he could be living a luxurious life
right now but instead he's sitting in an
airport hangar with these people
i could right now be having a very
beautiful life of luxury and here i am
at the hangar in
minnesota with 15 or 20 or 25
000.
and thousands of people that couldn't
get in and i'm working my ass off i
could be at home having a good time
wonderful time
but the one thing i say this
just complete cognitive dissonance trump
telling the crowd
i could be at my penthouse instead of
with you people
and they cheer we love trump amazing and
this
isn't all of it we will be looking after
the break
at one more rally in nevada
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches and they're giving you up to 30
off everything in their store when you
go to davidpakman.com
slash watch if you're looking for an
awesome way to
update your look the perfect way to do
it is with an elegant
high quality wrist watch when there's a
company like
vincero there is no reason to go
spending thousands of dollars on a watch
vincero is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video